Hello everybody, this is Peter Cooper from
NCBI.
Welcome to today's webinar on how to quickly
retrieve sequences from NCBI.
During the webinar if you have a question
please type it in the question pod.
My colleague Tao is here and he will try to
answer them in real time while we go through
the webinar.
If there are some particularly relevant ones
for everyone, we will take time at the end
to try to answer those.
For questions that we have, we will put the
answers in the document that will be available
after the webinar, linked to the webinar page.
I will go ahead and start the webinar.
We will talk today in sort of basic terms
about how to retrieve sequences from NCBI.
My name is Peter Cooper as I said.
You can write to me about any questions at
Peter dot Cooper at NCBI.gov.
I'll show you some other contact addresses
at the end of this.
We're basically going to learn how to display
and download sequences, using the NCBI webpages
. Something a lot of people are are not aware
how to do.
And how to bookmark sequences and things like
that using direct URLs.
Then we will switch over to the command line,
using Unix and Linux and the E-Utilities,
very briefly and then switch over to the EDirect
programs which is a simpler way of doing that.
We're going to talk first about accessing
sequences on the web and I'll show you a few
slides and then we will go live.
When you're downloading sequences are accessing
sequences in NCBI you will search for them
in the Entrez system.
Most people are aware of this system, they
may not be aware of the name.
We have gotten away from calling it that but
that is the way we call it here at NCBI.
We're going to use two main sequence databases
today, we will use, nucleotide or nuccore.
And the same things that I show you also apply
to the protein databases.
We will talk about the nucleotide but the
same applies to the protein sequences as well.
If you go to the Entrez system there are some
display formats, we will run a search and
get some sequences.
You see by default the Summary format, you
can get these various displays, GenBank, FASTA.
Those are the two I will emphasize.
THose are the URLs on the right side of the
slide to those web pages.
It's just the NCBI base URL (www.ncbi.nlm.nih.gov)
and the datagbase name (/nucleotide or /protein).
We'll come back in a minute when we talk about
bookmarking sequences.
So the two common formats that people run
into the most at our site are Genbank and
FASTA.
GenBank is human readable, it has a header
it has a sequence annotation, and the sequence
itself.
And it's the same format that is used on the
GenBank FTP.
The sequence we're going to be looking at
is a Reference Sequence, but the format is
still the GenBank format.
And then there is fasta, what most people
probably want when they're coming to get a
sequence.
It is a real simple format.
It has the title on one line with a greater
than sign that starts the title, and it has
a sequence on the subsequent lines.
FASTA, basically a universal format for sequence
analysis programs . We have a text version
of it, where you can copy and paste easily
even if you have multiple sequences.
One thing you notice about these is you can
not download these directly from the web browser
using the browser's file menu.
The way you get around that is use the Send
to menu.
In the upper right-hand corner of the displayed
pages.
If I click on that, it opens up and gives
me a bunch of radio buttons I can choose.
If I want to download a complete record you
can do that.
We'll come back to this later you can also
get the coding sequences or the gene features.
Things annotated on the record.
We choose the file, the destination, then
press that Create File button and download
in text format.
The options here, the three actually that
I'm going to talk about, are GenBank which
we already mentioned.
GenBank full, a special format that you will
have to use on large sequence records like
chromosome records because they will not have
the sequence in them.
And then FASTA which is the most important
for downloading.
And then there are other structured formats
we won't go into today . Also identifier lists.
We will focus on getting sequences.
Another topic I want to mention, the ability
to bookmark sequences.
There is a standard way you can link to a
record in the Entrez system.
NCBI base URL, database name, and the id that
is at the bottom of the slide . For example
if I want to link directly to a nucleotide
sequence, this one at the top, www.ncbi.nlm.nih.gov/nuccore/NM_000485.2
It is the base URL, the name of the database,
you can put nucleotide or nuccore here, then
the identifier which is the accession number.
And likewise I can add this feature at the
end, question mark report equals fasta, and
and you get the fasta.
And then finally you can link to the text
record by adding ampersand format equals text.
You can do this with more than one record,
comma separated.
Okay, that is all well and good.
But mostly that's for displaying things.
What we want to do is access sequences directly
without using a web browser, to get them locally
for us to use.
The standard way to do that is the E-Utilities
. This is NCBI's API.
It uses URLs to access the system.
These can be incorporated into scripts.
Basically there's a base URL, and a bunch
of server-side programs you run.
They do require that you write a custom wrapper
script to integrate search and retrieval.
An efetch example, which would basically do
the same thing we just saw on the bookmark
links, is listed at the bottom of the slide.
https://eutils.ncbi.nlm.nih.gov/entrez/efetch.fcgi?db=nucleotide&id=NM_000485.2&rettype=fasta
You have the base URL here.
It's kind of long.
And then you have the CGI program efetch.
The nucleotide databae, the id you want, and
the return type, in this case FASTA . That
gives you a FASTA formatted record for this
particular NCBI reference sequence.
That is fine if you're comfortable writing
scripts.
There is a set of scripts that NCBI has made
called Entrez direct . Basically a commandline
version of the EUtilities.
These programs run on UNIX or Linux operating
system.
You can basically use them to do things like
sequence search and retrieval.
We will focus mainly today and retrieval.
Which means we will use this program called
efetch . There's a lot more to Entrez Direct
but we won't go into it today .
Why do you want to use this?
It lets you get the sequences directly with
batch access without a web browser and most
importantly there is no scripting required.
So this is a slide about EDirect.
We're going to be looking at that center section,
We will basically perform a search and then
use efetch to download this.
There's a lot more to it, you have a parser
in there if you get the xml format.
If you want to know more about how to use
EDirect, we did an one hour webinar on this
and you can watch the recording on our YouTube
channel.
Follow this link.
https://youtu.be/BLnYW33Mtb0
How these programs work?
They work in a very similar way to the way
Entrez works so you run a search using the
esearch program.
And this will put some things in the Entrez
history which you don't need to worry about.
Then I use the UNIX pipe and then put it into
this program efetch , and then I will get
some format, in this case I just asked for
the accession numbers.
$ esearch -db nucleotide -query "human[organism]
AND APRT[title] AND refseq[filter] | efetch
-format acc
For the sequence databases there are lots
of formats available in Entrez Direct.
Many of these you see on the pulldown list
on the web.
There are lots of additional ones, some additional
ones here because you have an XML format,
text format, for example for the GenBank flat
file.
When you're working with these you will see
if you want to know what the options are type
the name of the program then dash help.
In order to use these you have to install
them and the information on how to do that
I won't go over today.
It's very straightforward.
If you go to the Entrez Direct help documents
that I will point out in a little bit, you
should be able to install them simply on any
UNIX type system.
For more information about E direct a really
good place to go for recipes for how do you
do certain things is this cookbook available
on the NCBI Hackathons GitHub site.
The URL is in the center of this slide.
https://github.com/NCBI-Hackathons/EDirect_EUtils_API_Cookbook
Okay, what I want to do now are live demonstrations
of how to manage these kinds of things on
the web and then we'll work on the command
line.
I will escape from the sides.
And I will go over here to the web browser.
And I am going to go through some examples.
Let's work with a particular set of genes
and gene products.
What I will do first is get human sequences.
I will do an organism fielded search.
And I will type the name of the gene APRT,
which is adenine phosphoribosyl transferase.
We will search the nucleotide database.
You can select it from this pulldown list
or Google it directly.
So I already had my RefSeq filter on, I can
take that off, you can see the difference
if you don't have that on.
So I get 22 but I will reduce it down to seven.
And so, this is interesting to notice what
kind of records we have.
We have transcript variants from APRT.
We have this RefSeqGene record which is a
standalone record which represents that genomic
region plus some sequence on either side of
the gene.
We also have some additional RefSeqGene records
because the flanking sequence contains parts
of these genes here, also on chromosome 16.
And we have the entire chromosome 16 record
here, two versions of it, one from the primary
assembly and one from the CHM one assembly.
I will work with the first three sequences.
I don't want to deal with downloading that
human chromosome.
In the pulldown list I can change the format
easily.
We can change it to GenBank .
And we get all of the records here in GenBank
format, human readable, with lots of information
on the annotation on the records.
Or we can choose FASTA .
And there are the three records in FASTA format.
What a lot of people do, they select these.
You select them one at a time and copy and
paste them into an text file or sometimes
they paste them into the BLAST tool.
Notice you don't need to do that by the way.
You can get a set of sequences on the webpage
here and click the Run BLAST button and it
will take the accessions and put them in the
BLAST form, you're ready to go.
This is still a little bit inconvenient so
there's another more convenient way to get
these if you want to select all three sequence
at once.
There is a FASTA (text) version here.
There they are.
If I select and copy and paste these, I will
get these in text format.
In a way that is convenient, but it's not
convenient if I was trying to do this with
hundreds of sequences.
So in order to do that we use the Send to
menu on the right-hand side.
Of course as I pointed out if you wanted to
save these with the web browser function,
you just get a web page with all the HTML
stuff and you don't want that.
You can use the send to menu here.
Choose file as the destination.
And then quickly download the FASTA format
, you saw what that looks like.
You can also download the GenBank format and
if I was dealing with that chromosome 16 record
I would use the GenBank full format.
There's a bunch of other formats here that
we won't go into today . basically structured
formats of various kinds.
Also an identifier list.
And relatively recently the GFF, another way
of looking at the annotation.
One useful thing here is to get the coding
sequences, just to show you how that works.
Let me go back and grab one of these really
quick.
I will retrieve this sequence.
This is the transcript variant one.
Notice there is a feature called the CDS.
The CDS I can highlight.
It starts with a start codon and ends with
the stop codon.
So this is part of this messenger RNA sequence
that is translated into protein.
We can get those for all of the records in
the list if we want to.
For things like messenger RNAs it will be
nice and simple, one coding region.
For the gene record we will have several of
them corresponding to perhaps different transcript
splice variants that are annotated on the
gene record.
And also the fact this particular record will
have parts of other genes besides APRT.
So just to show you a download format, I will
do Send to.
I will send the coding sequences.
And I will download FASTA nucleotide . I will
put that on my desktop.
I will call it CDS.txt.
And I will go back here and I'm going to drop
it into this.
You can see, you get these nice coding regions
with very nice structured deflines, telling
you what gene it is, where it is and those
types of things.
You can also, see the various coding regions
on this RefSeqGene record.
These are very handy for what coding regions
are on there.
In some cases some of these are partial.
And then there's a complete one, of course
for the APRT gene.
Okay, so, we already talked sufficiently in
the slides about how to bookmark the sequences,
you can easily follow the instructions in
the slides.
What I want to do now is go to the command
line, to show you a couple of things there.
I am now logged onto a UNIX system at the
NCBI . I can do various things here.
One of the things I could do is put one of
those eutilities URLs and do that.
That is not particularly what you want to
have to do.
You want to be able to use the programs esearch
and efetch to get things.
Let's talk about that.
Let's first reproduce the search that we had
in the slides a minute ago.
Just to save myself some typing I will get
it out of this text file I have.
It is on the ftp site.
If you want to reproduce these yourself you
can.
Let me put this in here first.
I have changed the search slightly.
So that it is more complicated, it APRT in
the title, that's make sure I get just those
three sequences.
I don't want to deal with the human chromosome
sequence.
There is the Unix pipe.
And I want the format Acc.
So I have the three accession numbers I was
interested in before . I can use my up arrow
key to get that back.
And I can use get one of the other formats
I talked about FASTA . And if I want to, to
make it nicer, what will happen is it will
dump it to the screen so I can put it to a
file if I want to.
Just call it APRT dot fna if I want to.
Let's just do that.
And we can just take a look at what is in
the file by using the UNIX program more.
And you can see I have the FASTA sequences.
I will scroll through here.
The three records we talked about .
Suppose I want to know what format strings
do I need to use that to get the various formats
we talked about.
For any of the EDirect programs, just type
the name and a dash and the word help.
I will pipe this into the program more so
we can scroll through it.
Here are the various format arguments you
can use for the different databases.
The ones we are interested in are the sequence
databases of course.
So you can see here, we have already used
FASTA . You can ask for the coding region,
even amino acids.
So even if you're starting with a nucleotide,
I should've pointed this out, you can ask
for the amino acid sequence.
Or the CDS nucleic acid that we got from the
webpage.
And here are all the other possibilities.
I will clear my screen.
Instead of format FASTA, you can type nucleic
acid.
I will let that scroll so you can see it.
It looks like what we downloaded a while ago.
So you can see some of the different coding
regions here including ones, this is the RefSeqGene
record with the coding sequences from the
mRNA sequences.
You can also do this on the web to bookmark
regions of sequences if you want to.
But you can use the seq_start and seq_stop
arguments here to get a region of a sequence.
Let's do something fairly big.
Let's try hromosome 16.
I can get a region of chromosome 16 that contains
the APRT gene.
And we'll get it in GenBank format so we can
browse through and find various gene features
that are on there.
So to save myself some thinking, well, what
the heck why don't I type it.
I will go to the database I want to use, I
can use nucleotide.
So DB is nucleotide.
ID, I have to know the accesession number
I want.
Chromosome 16, those are pretty easy to remember,
NC_000016.
You don't have to use the version.
I do have to use the right number of zeros
though.
I can give it some arguments.
These are things I determined ahead of time,
where the genes are that I am interested in.
I can pass the argument seq_start.
And seq_stop.
And then we can ask for a format, GenBank,
so it will give us that GenBank flatfile format.
Checking my numbers here.
And this takes a minute.
Let's let it run for a second.
Because it is retrieving a very large record.
It basically tries to get the whole thing
down before it does anything.
While that is happening let me go back to
the slides for a moment.
So we showed you had a access sequences using
the web system, we bookmarked some URLs.
We showed you how to use commandline access
using EDirect to get sequences.
The last slide has a bunch of places where
you can go to get more information about EDirect
and the other things we talked about today.
Let me go back and see if this thing came
back.
Before I leave this slide, remind you that
if you have any questions about NCBI resources
you can write to us at info@ncbi.nlm.nih.gov
If you have questions about webinars in general,
the webinar program can be reached at webinars@ncbi.nlm.nih.gov.
Let's see if this finished.
Yep.
I downloaded a portion of chromosome 16.
53,765 base pairs.
It tells me what the region it is.
I got the complementary strand.
That's why the seq_start was higher than the
seq_stop because the gene we are interested
in happens to be on the complement.
I get the complete feature table here.
And I'll use more to find the APRT gene.
And here it is . The two splice variants annotated
on the record.
And the coding region.
And so on and so forth.
Okay.
We will stop there.
We will have some time to answer a few questions
if anyone has any.
Let me take a look at them.
Okay so we answered some of these in the process
of the webinar.
One question is the range of an accession
, you can use a colon to separate the two
accession numbers.
The range maybe talking about the one where
I showed you you can have a start and a stop.
Okay so this is an intereesting one.
Does it split the coding region into exons
that can be I easily identified.
No it does not.
In that particular format.
Now there is, If you looked at the feature
table for one of the reference sequences,
the mRNA RefSeq that I looked at.
Those do have the exons annotated on them.
And so do the RefSeqGene records.
You could parse them out in another way.
So there was a clarification about the range.
Can I ask for range more than one range of
a sequence at the same time?
The answer to that as far as I know is no.
You can ask for a start in a stop, but you
cannot get multiple segments of a sequence.
I will look that.
When we put the document up I'll see if I
can find the answer to that.
I don't think that is possible if I understand
the question correctly.
>> Okay.
Let's wrap this up, it is 12:30 PM.
Thank you everybody for coming.
We will see you next time.